welcome back everyone we
we still don't have a name
it's just a cosmic Wonder podcast right
does it need a name
we talked about marble and and and
sometimes DC and Star Wars and other
stuff welcome back welcome wherever
you're listening uh uh we should be up
on Apple and Spotify if you're you know
somebody who just wants to listen not
watch the video hello to YouTube if
you're here uh I'm Lauren and this is La
hello everyone log back
um you know last time we talked about
the future of the MCU after Secret Wars
we talked about if it should reset or
not thanks for all the feedback that you
guys gave us in that video in the
comments saw a lot of mixed reactions
there which is which is basically what I
expected and I think we're all
have mixed feelings inside as well about
it you know there's good and bad to each
thing but today we want to talk about
right now I think there's I think
there's gonna be a big kind of like
paradigm shift in the MCU because of
Loki
I think Loki's gonna like really bring
us into like what is supposed to be like
the true
Multiverse Saga right because we haven't
felt it like too much yet right I mean
like we felt it a little bit
but oddly enough everything hasn't been
like so connected like like
Loki wasn't that connected to like
Spider-Man no way home Doctor Strange
the Multiverse of Madness wasn't even
that connected to it really right I mean
it's like
it's interesting yeah but I feel like
that's about to change after looking
season two because it's we're diving
back in and we're getting like not just
one variant of Kang but now multiple
variants of Kang
and I feel like it's just gonna feel
more
like this is what it's supposed to be
about and this is how it's supposed to
feel what do you think about that you
get what I'm saying yeah that's an
interesting way to look at it because
you know when we watched Loki season one
and I think a lot of audiences would
agree we all thought that was going to
be the starting point for like a big
multiversal kind of cluster F you know
exactly exactly yeah but as as you know
we more projects release it it almost
was like the MCU was like oh these are
all different breaks in the Multiverse
but they don't necessarily like compound
with each other like they all happened
at once you know like we could blame
Sylvie for one we could blame Doctor
Strange for another
but I like the idea of like coming back
to it in a much bigger way especially
because quantumania did not fulfill like
the king big bad Vibe for me whereas
Loki totally did that in season one like
when he who remains shows up he gives
you a big scale of like what went down
and it would be disappointing to never
see that I think we talked about this in
the last podcast where it's just like
what are the stakes like how is he
affecting different timelines and then
if Loki season two because it like the
trailer is a banger I'll say that right
now
let's do a really good job of the
trailers I would say it's really good
and and you know it's putting Tom in
like or in Logie in like a very almost
heroic role
um it more so than the first season
because you know he was like for sure
coming to terms with his new existence
right yeah but all that to say I would
be super down to see this become the
major threat because we have big
projects like Secret Wars coming up in
King Dynasty and stuff yeah actually on
that point I I did a Loki video
maybe yesterday
I do a video every day sometimes two
videos a day sometimes it's hard for me
to keep track
um
but I it's funny I retain all the
information but I can't tell you like
the order that I put out the information
um
but it was a Kevin Wright executive
producer for for Loki season two
said that that is actually a story arc
of this for Loki is actually more heroic
than we've ever seen him uh and it's it
was a um I remember what it was it was
it was one of the kind of like behind
yeah what do they call them
yeah yeah it was a featurette and you
know it's uh Tom Hiddleston kind of
talking behind the scenes Kevin Wright
talking behind the scenes and and I
think Tom Hiddleston says something like
uh you know he just cares about his
friends now like the people which is
like so not like Loki he yeah like and
and Logan said too he's just gonna care
about his friends and and doing what's
right I think because we hear them say
in like the first trailer I think it was
that we got where she's like we're we're
playing God and he's like we are Gods
yeah because essentially they're gonna
kind of take over the TVA and they can
kind of decide what to do from here on
out
and that's the real and that's that's
that's that's where the big decision
comes in because like you said like he
who remains in Loki season one in the
finale was like
it was such a great performance by
Jonathan Majors because I I'm just like
wow you really it's like you said you
really feel
that he's like a big major threat and he
shows you like oh there's a big
Multiverse battle and he's like and then
I I won I took Elias powers and I won
excuse me
and then it's like
okay that was the guy we saw him going
to missions you know is it I saw
something the other day that was like
the worst decision Marvel ever made was
to have was to introduce their big bad
and and quantumanian have him lose I'm
like I'm maybe not the worst decision
they made but definitely one of them
it's a weakness I would agree yeah for
sure like if you wanted to showcase the
power that you showed us or that you you
teased us with and scared us with in
Loki season one like you didn't do a
very good job with that but
um but Loki's now going to be faced with
kind of the future of the Multiverse
because he's got a he's gonna kind of be
like how do we kind of shut it all down
and get the the main timeline to be kind
of secluded like this guy did or should
we even do that because then we are
killing timelines we're killing
trillions of people right it's like you
know so it's a big decision but that
scope of now there's all these timelines
and the Multiverse and everything like
that that's what we want to feel and I
know that's coming with Loki and to take
it even further so much of what we've
heard about Deadpool 3 is gonna be that
too
yeah and then
we've heard that you know like that some
stuff in between Kang Dynasty and Secret
Wars is gonna be possibly take place
Another Universe like the Fantastic Four
movie possibly being a different
universe and I I
I remember I can't remember who said it
one of the Insiders uh could have been
trying to think
I don't know I don't want to say the
wrong person uh so I won't say anybody
at all but one of the Insiders like can
we get some toast my time Sean alone one
of them
um said something like
there was a person in the Illuminati in
the a38 universe that wasn't actually
there that is still alive and it's gonna
have a bone to pick
with our universe and that person is the
person responsible for creating those
Ultron bots so I'm I wanna like believe
it's Superior Iron Man
yeah yeah and they said that that will
actually be addressed at some point
so I'm like well that's cool because now
we have conflict between Heroes of of
universe like they're Heroes but they're
of different universes so it's not just
gonna be like the Multiverse Saga isn't
just gonna be like everybody fighting
Kang like there's gonna be evil people
or people who simply have both I think
they're in the right right exactly
exactly so there's gonna be a lot of
different conflict and it's gonna be
really cool to see yeah and everybody
has been waiting everybody's been
yes we are waiting but everybody's
looking forward to that a lot yeah and
we haven't felt it yet I feel yeah and
at least not to the scale we expected it
exactly exactly I think everybody
thought like you said like when Loki
came out from there
it was like we're gonna start feeling it
in a lot of shows and movies
maybe not all of them but a lot and and
we haven't but
and we were like the problem is we're
also kind of like teased with like no
way home Multiverse and Madness like
I I I really loved no way home
um I know some people like after the
fact like months later years later are
like yeah it was so good I don't care
I'm like I I'm like fan service I'm like
I like fan service like if it's done
right like I like it like there's no
it's also the MCU that's like right 30
of the enjoyment Factor yeah exactly if
it's done right like I love it yeah but
again like the way everything connected
it didn't
right so now I feel like with because
Mobius is supposed to appear in Deadpool
3. and of course obviously everything
going on with the Multiverse and the TVA
and Loki season two
from here on out things have to really
start to connect or it's gonna be like
you're gonna be rushing way too much at
the King Dynasty and Secret Wars yeah
it's just gonna be a rush yeah and I
think we've seen I mean like
when you have a title like Doctor
Strange Multiverse of Madness on its own
a good movie a solid movie
I'll interrupt you real quick because a
lot of people crapped on that movie too
but it won
movie of the year for like I don't
remember what but like MTV or something
like that like actually one movie of the
year no People's Choice okay you know
what it's still still a damn good ride
right and like when you're not when you
don't factor in the scale of the
Multiverse it still works as a good
movie sure now like opportunities within
that movie would have been like Scarlet
what's traveling Multiverse is seeing a
version of Kane like something like that
right especially with America Chavez's
power we didn't get that no way home it
kind of wraps up in a bow no one
remembers Peter Parker but it's like it
it didn't it didn't address kind of the
big
gaping hole that Loki season one created
and then now we have all these different
obviously these different King variants
at the end of quantumania that's gonna
have to lead somewhere but really when I
think about what I care about I'm more
interested in Loki's version of Kang and
like his story because he came back and
the TVA was completely changed does that
mean history was Rewritten is he in a
new universe how does heat oh God living
oh you do know yeah
you can piece it together
if you've seen like all the featurettes
and all the trailers and stuff like that
ah I see so I mean I'll
should I keep quiet
let's let them speculate well I've
mention it in videos oh you do okay yeah
so what is it we'll talk about this in
detail in just a bit but first big thank
you to hellofresh for sponsoring this
video many of you may know that I
personally use hellofresh and I love it
it makes cooking fun easy and it's
affordable and that's why it's America's
number one meal kit delivered straight
to your door and you might not know that
they actually have seasonal recipes
right now since it's summer they have
their new fresh and fit summer menu so
if you're trying to get that beach bud
but you're also trying to eat really
great tasting food it's perfect for you
right now it's peak time for summer
produce and hellofresh make sure you get
all the best picks all season long their
ingredients travel from the farm to your
door in less than seven days for Quality
you can taste if you are trying to
impress your friends this summer by
doing some cooking for them hellofresh
makes it super simple they give you all
of the ingredients and tell you exactly
how to make each meal and the best part
is right now you can go to
hellofresh.com
50 Cosmic and use code 50 Cosmic for 50
off plus 15 off the next two months
that's hellofresh.com 50 Cosmic and use
code 50 Cosmic for 50 off plus 15 off
the next two months I mean he basically
gets they say it in in the in the I
think it's the first trailer they showed
like he time glitches he's time slipping
right right so basically he ends up
back in time of the TBA and that's why
so if you look in the trailer you can
see him kind of like prune a wall that
shows the timekeepers and behind it is a
picture of King
so that's actually in present time
but he goes back and he ends up back
into the past in the TVA where Kang has
not hid himself and introduced the
timekeeper's yet I don't know why I
don't know what happens I don't know
like
what happens at TVA to make Ken go crap
I don't want people to know it's me I'm
gonna invent the timekeepers
I don't know how that happens but based
off of some things I've heard and just
the trailers confirming speculations I
had of my own that is pretty much what I
believe happens is he ends up back in a
previous
point in time in the TBA to where Kang
is still openly ruling it and he's still
and he's slipping through different
dimensions just be right so it won't
just be that point in time clearly we've
seen the trailer that he goes right yeah
multiple times I still like
I still there's that one scene where
he's in a jet ski dealership and I'm
like hoping behind him is hidden Mobius
getting a jet ski we see that I know all
of us were that was the only thing we
all wanted that's right but we're like
there's a season two we know the season
two please give it to us yeah uh yeah no
uh so
but there is like to your point there is
so much
that needs to like pay off yeah that we
have that hasn't paid off yet
and I think Loki's gonna give season two
is gonna give that to us and it's
interesting because it's still a TV it's
technically still a TV show so why do
you think this is the opportunity
well I was about to say Loki
the first season
I don't I've never actually sat there
and I know other YouTubers do this I
should have done this but I've never sat
there just ranked everything I'm never
like this is my favorite this is my blah
blah blah you know what I mean
um I probably should I'll do that soon
that's a different video
um but without a doubt Loki is probably
my top three of movies and shows just
anything just projects in general yeah
oh I loved love yeah it is by it I
shouldn't say by far because I loved one
division as well but it is it was by far
one of my top favorite MCU projects
hosting game
and
yeah I mean I don't know what else would
really be up there with it yeah chunky
I mean there's a lot of great I I'm
actually one of the people who do
believe there's a lot of great things
that have come out of phase four and
phase five so far
um like Moon night oh my God Moon night
Guardians I mean right right exactly
like there's yeah even the Guardians
holiday special I thought was awesome
that was so good yeah yeah so you know
um and now I'm now I'm called the Disney
show right because I say that but watch
why it's so funny someone recently said
like I love everything I'm like did you
like I did you not hear my review for
the finale of secret Invasion because I
hated it yeah not hated it I can't say I
hated it but yeah I I tore into it but
I I just think Loki I think Loki really
is
people's like favorite top five whatever
yeah projects and there's so much
like that comes into play with it
because just the character obviously
people obviously okay and it's so cool
to see him be such a true narcissist and
fall in love with himself a variant of
himself like yeah it's so good they did
say
oh I want to say it was like an
Entertainment Weekly article or
something that's one of those other
things as well I always read articles
and interviews and stuff so I mix them
up as well but in some interview they
did say that that is going to be
addressed some more their romantic
relationship between Sylvia lucky so I'm
looking forward to that so but just like
the overall Vibe of it the feel of it
but then it's the heaviness of it
because one of the first things that you
see in the the first half of Loki is the
Infinity Stones aren't crap look it's
like is this the greatest power
in in the universe and it's like uh well
kind of yeah
uh it doesn't really exist I guess in a
specific Universe maybe they're gonna
have to further
carve out those details to us right sure
because because one of the things I had
I was like well how is how is Loki back
in time in the TVA if it exists outside
of space and time and I read an article
that said that will be addressed
it's kind of like an end game how you
can go back in time or time can go
through you
kind of one of those things kind of one
of those things you know what I mean you
also like Eugene Cordero is back Casey
yeah you know and and a couple of Clips
in the trailer it looks like he's in
danger yeah yeah then you also have like
Ki Quan is here kiwan uh he's playing
character oroboros
um which is interesting to me because
that the symbol of an oroboros is a
snake eating its own pail
and and I wonder if that has to do with
like the grand scheme of the Season like
we're we're doomed to repeat our
mistakes regardless right and I because
it's like maybe Loki realizes that like
you know what he who remembers was kind
of right because look at all these
variants coming so
yeah that's a great Point that's that's
good detail there there's a line in this
trailer where he talks about being the
god of Mischief always has been the god
of Mischief right yeah do we foresee
this version of Loki becoming the god of
the Multiverse almost you know like I I
I like what you're saying there because
I've actually thought before I'm like
you know who's gonna defeat Kang it's
Loki it would be it would be so sick if
it was Loki right no and it it really
would be but if you think about it right
now
who knows the most about Kang or I
should say is going to because yeah I
guess Janet Van Dyne knows the most okay
if she knew she would have told somebody
sorry one of my big grapes
yeah right you would imagine like oh I I
trapped him in there no way he's gonna
get out like she's like don't mess with
the Multiverse with a Quantum burst it's
like why Mom I don't want to talk about
it that's something you should have
talked about Michelle Pfeiffer come on
yeah
uh
uh the original wasp Janet Van Dyne is
the reason the Multiverse is uh
The Avengers gonna lose so yeah give it
up for the the original wasp
yeah but no I I would argue you know I
during Loki season two
well actually she might she might
Loki probably knows the most because he
remains explained everything like hey
there was this one guy another Universal
on top of the other universe and they
visited each other then war broke out
then I harnessed Goliath and I have to
do this you don't understand the TVA is
the necessary evil and everything that
he said was gonna happen if they killed
him is happening
and I would love for the the
No One Division was first we'll say it
was was lucky the first thing to come
from phase four one division was before
it Wando a vision but but it was in the
beginning so it's like and then at the
end it's like lucky you know what I mean
so yeah
I would love for that but even talking
it's so funny even talking about
everything that we've talked about in
this episode makes me feel more like it
is the Multiverse now yeah which is
which is like the whole point of this
discussion is
I I don't
I don't like the is the MCU dead talk
we've had it
um let me rephrase I don't mind talking
about it but people who are like oh the
MCU is dead I'm like I don't think it's
ever gonna be dead like yeah and an
in-game kind of really just made us feel
like everything's just gonna be a banger
when it's like it's not right so
that talk is is interesting but I think
whatever those people are feeling this
is my point and and I never shame
anybody for having their own personal
opinion if you think it's dead I'm sorry
that sucks I'm not saying you're wrong
that's why you're not enjoying that's
your feeling right I am genuinely sorry
you're not joining anymore but I hope
Loki is something that lucky season two
is something that shifts that that we
have that paradigm shift in the MCU
because that is what I think I because
again even after just talking about it
in this episode I'm like excited and
then all of the stuff that's gonna
happen in Deadpool three I've heard so
much yeah that was experience right
battle world might be the thing you know
the the TVA kind of taking people from
all these universes put them in one
world like that's gonna be crazy man
with all that stuff that we've heard up
there is true about Deadpool 3 like
that's gonna be insane so you know just
go in four and then and then on top of
that like Captain America four supposed
to start the new Avengers team stuff
like that like I feel like it's really
all coming together now yeah right like
almost
you know people talk about phase four
being like the new experimental phase of
Marvel that's probably true you know
introducing some new characters doing
Disney plus stuff you know yeah
but I think really it's about the film
more connected again I I also think you
you mentioned it before I think a big
thing that would support this kind of
big shift like a shift in the universe
is the fact that it's Loki Loki has been
with us since
whenever Thor came out 2010 2009 or
whatever yeah yeah you know what I mean
and so whether it was the Loki that we
was like messing with the Avengers or
this Loki that you know really does come
up in end game right that was that that
that's where we pull this one from right
yeah everyone has some kind of
relationship or history with this
character what in universe and as
audiences like we all know who Loki is
we all know what variants are uh we all
love Tom Hiddleston right it would make
a lot of sense to give him the brunt of
responsibility for for like
for because he teased the threat and I
would love if he was the reason that he
fixes the threat too or at least like
attacks the threat because Loki is so
powerful and we saw you know the Richard
Grant version yeah this illusion yeah so
and I'm just like yeah I bet Tom can do
something bigger though you know what I
mean like right yeah I bet this Loki
given everything that he's learned with
this heroic path he's on yep I I think
you might be onto something because like
I would actually love that as a as a
proper entryway to the Multiverse I I
think
I think Loki's
it plays a huge part in Saving the
Multiverse yes yeah because it just
makes sense story wise like everything
he's he's learned you know what I mean
yeah everything he knows and to your
point there is a part in one of the
trailers I think it was a more recent
one where like Loki and Sylvie grab
hands and they seemingly like use their
powers together to make it stronger
so he is definitely learning more and
you know Sylvie is the one who taught
him a little bit Yeah in season one as
well so I think by the end of this he's
going to be really really powerful yeah
really and we've seen you know him
create those like Shadow illusions that
actually physically grab yeah uh so some
new Loki powers are going to be shown
and I'm just really excited to see
how the story plays out yeah with with
these variants because we have at least
two
um Victor timely right and he remains as
apparently coming back coming back or
like Canada or something another you
have to wonder like I mean he did say
I'll see you soon
but you have to wonder like okay who is
it really there you know sure yeah yeah
but yeah I feel
I I haven't been this excited in a long
time because because Loki is literally
the next thing that's coming out yeah
and I just feel like from here it's just
gonna get really
really exciting really connected really
good
and I hope
I hope that's how it is for a lot of
fans as well
I hope people don't feel like Marvel's
dying after this
well I think like you know bringing it
back to an OG character that we love
that's like yeah that I like what that
does something to the soul I think
especially when you consider there's not
like you know Captain America's gone
Iron Man's gone God yeah Hope's not the
same yeah yeah and people have things to
say about that right exactly you know
what
it's kind of goofy I'll say this this
was kind of be my last point it's goofy
when you see all the gangs in the tri
the tribunal and they're like they're
cheering yeah but I'm actually kind of
hyped off the idea of all of those kings
facing off an army of Loki Illusions
super cool I'm kind of into that like
why wouldn't we have that you know I
mean that's that's a Marvel thing to do
a giant CGI army fight at the end
of a movie totally and then follow the
main the main ones that's it right just
have it in the background yeah
a lot of a lot a lot of exciting things
yeah to look forward to a lot of stuff
what you guys think about this are you
excited for looking season two I hope
everyone says yes if not I hope you
still watch it and get excited uh
because I think it's gonna bring
at least a really big tonal shift to the
MCU as it is right now I will say if
you're not excited let us know why
please I would genuinely be curious yeah
let us know why yeah maybe superhero
fatigue right it's real for some people
uh but we'll see I think this is going
to be a banger I think it's gonna be I
hope it's 10 out of 10 and like you said
Loki is just he's an OG I'm excited for
him so unless all your thoughts and
please let us know if you're not excited
for it like lost said and uh yeah we'll
catch you on the next episode we enjoy
doing these so look out for that see you
guys